[Music]
you're an OG of reality tell em you
better pedal like browse y'all og
the original HBIC you are what are these
new reality TV kids what are they doing
wrong what can you teach them um I don't
think they're being honest enough I
think they're trying to play up the
cameras and sell their products but they
need to just take a step back and want
some of my old footage if you want to
know how to be like the old G and to be
the Warriors you really need to run some
oh I Love New York and Flavor of Love
yes I mean do you watch The Bachelor who
on there right now well I'm just
wondering because you say push their
product that kind of thing are these
people on The Bachelor real it's reality
TV but are they being real they're
trying to be real but they're not coming
off as 100% authentic I can sense a
little bit of fakeness in there a little
bit a little bit does it blow your mind
how much reality TV has changed since
you were on Flavor of Love and I Love
New York yes I'm mad I'm mad I'm mad and
I'm disgruntled because all these I'm
making so much money right now and I
didn't capitalize like that back in my
day there was no Instagram girl there
was no Instagram there was no Twitter
and it got shoe lines and hair lines and
makeup lines and on it I'm trying to
catch up
well you're catching up you're on
famously single why do you think that
you are or were famously single oh why
am i famously single because it's hard
to date when you're this no we're this
popular people just want to capitalize
you know the guys just want to see me as
New York and capitalize but know I have
a heart have love I have passion like
cakes I'm into charity nobody
understands these things about me I have
a heart like I have so much going on and
people are gonna get to see that and
famously say I hope so and I think that
people are gonna get to see this this
Sunday night
we single only on a at 10:00 p.m. I want
them to see a new side of me do you
think they'll see it I've seen it
already in those first couple episodes
it's good there's so much fun to watch
and you also show that vulnerability
gorilla thank you so much for that I
need it back
[Music]
you